[Musica]
moda sostenibile esiste
spesso spesso leggiamo questa parola
ormai quotidianamente sono un 3 4 volte
al giorno ma quando leggiamo questa
parola forse
c'è la definizione sbagliata quello che
ho visto il mio percorso che quando
viene data la definizione sbagliata ad
un termine spesso questo si traduce in
politiche sbagliate e se guardiamo alle
politiche di sviluppo sostenibile che
l'industria della moda che ormai parla
di sostenibilità da ormai da sette anni
ha messo in atto negli ultimi anni
devo dire che un uno due tre dubbi
dovrebbe venirci rispetto alle concrete
efficacia di quello che ha fatto perché
se ne parla ormai da dieci anni ma
vediamo che da un lato le emissioni di
co2 non fa un altro commentare
dall'altro il divario sociale non le
ingiustizie sociali nei confronti di chi
crea i nostri vestiti non fanno altro
che aumentare
ci siamo venduti
e questo me ne sono reso conto negli
anni anch'io sbagliando siamo venduti
per anni l'illusione che basta su una
tecnologia un materiale un processo
innovativo
da inserire nel prodotto per
immediatamente gridare alla maglietta
sostenibile algie sostenibile perché se
magari oggettivamente arriviamo poi a
realizzare un prodotto che secondo certe
dimensione dal punto di vista del
consumo idrico del consumo energetico
abbassa l'impatto ambientale
ma quando questa questa maggiore
efficienza viene utilizzata e sfruttata
come giustificazione per continuare
perpetuare un business model che si basa
sostanzialmente sulla produzione il
nuovo essenziale è esponenzialmente
crescente di capi d'abbigliamento
abbiamo tutti lermani strapieni allora
allora l'impatto assoluto in realtà
aumenta e quindi come fare
io mi occupo di moda sostenibile sono
sono un ex in realtà responsabile della
nostra stabilità del settore e quando mi
sono trovato di fronte il problema ha
detto se le politiche non funzionano
bisogna per forza di cose ripartire
dalla definizione che cosa vuol dire
sostenibilità nel xix secolo un signore
tedesco e signor phone karlovic utilizzò
per la prima volta un termine nakhal di
kite che significava per lui una sorta
di rigenerazione della foresta bisognava
essere attenti stare molto attenti a
ripiantare ogni singolo albero che
veniva tagliato per supportare quella
che era una industria di cui lui era
corresponsabile a quella mineraria si
parla quindi di rigenerazione
xix secolo un secolo dopo una delle
prime definizioni politiche
il brut l'under porto nel 1987 dice
attenzione sostenibilità e ogni azione
che ci consenta a noi esseri umani di
vivere il nostro presente e al tempo
stesso garantire alle generazioni future
di fare quella stessa azione
domani
entrambe le definizioni nel mio percorso
che hanno aiutato effettivamente a
capire come essere distratti nei
confronti dell'industria della moda però
però però non sono esaustive la prima
perché non tiene conto del fatto che non
poteva farlo essendo secolo che che i
limiti fisici della terra ormai sono
sono incapaci di rigenerare le nostre
risorse siamo arrivati è un limite tale
per cui samhain possiamo è impossibile
continuare a rigenerarsi e stare al
passo con questi tassi di crescita così
elevati così intensi che il nostro
sistema economico impone dall'altro
invece abbiamo un modello fortemente
troppo centrico si parla dell'uomo si
parla delle azioni dell'uomo della
capacità dell'uomo di cooperazione oggi
senza interferire con le azioni
dell'uomo domani e l'ecosistema non ci
si pone neanche il dubbio che forse le
azioni dell'uomo potrebbero interferire
invece con altre specie viventi che
devono essere considerate al pari eque
all'essere umano
e che le nostre azioni su quelle pro
sistema potrebbero e qualche modo
interferire con le nostre
allora negli anni inciampo per caso in
un altra definizione qualche passo
indietro rispetto quella del brutale
avere porte negli anni 70 che sono stati
anni per speciali perché per la prima
volta tantissimi artisti filosofi
scrittori critici iniziano ad
interrogarsi su quali potessero essere
gli effetti di questo boom economico che
improvvisamente al mondo occidentale
inizia ad alimentare e uno tra tanti
questo filosofo tedesco johann as dice
in modo molto semplice
sostenibile ogni azione che è
compatibile con la preservazione
la vita sulla terra di una semplicità
disarmante ma in tre parole ha detto
tutto
in prima battuta si rende conto che
l'essere umano per la prima volta
arrivato grazie all'innovazione
tecnologica o ad un punto tale da da
essere in grado di interferire con degli
equilibri ecosistemici compiendo delle
azioni e si rende conto che l'essere
umano così facendo la distruggendo
l'ecosistema di cui parte e ripeto non
solo è parte integrante ma è parte equa
rispetto tutti gli altri organismi
potrebbe in qualche modo inficiare sulla
stessa sua sopravvivenza come tonato
suicida e la moda rispetto a tutto
questo come come si pone sostenibilità
vuol dire tutto questo moda sostenibile
quindi dovrebbe essere la maglietta
addosso tra i pantaloni che sto
indossando dovrà essere prodotto in modo
tale da garantire essere compatibile con
la preservazione della vita sulla terra
ed effettivamente così
quando guardo quello che indosso di con
la camicia di lino cotone organico pet
riciclato sono ingredienti materiali che
vengono bollati come sostenibile oggi
però se si guarda un po più a livello
microscopico quello che sta notando sto
indossando terra acqua aria energia
ma non solo gli stessi ingredienti che
utilizziamo per fare il pane solo che da
un lato abbiamo un industria l'industria
alimentare effettivamente serve per
garantire la sopravvivenza sul pianeta
al pane acqua
per supportare la vita di 8 miliardi sul
pianeta quasi 10 miliardi o ma fra
qualche anno dall'altro invece abbiamo
un industria che ecco il primo dato
stiamo arrivando stiamo arrivando
ragazza a 102 milioni di tonnellate di
vestiti che utilizzano risorse
essenziali per garantire la vita sul
pianeta
a che pro
a questi livelli
e chiaro allora che anch'io sbagliando
ripeto perché siamo in transito
e quando sia in transito bisogna fare
ricerca continua a studiare anche
sbagliando mi rendo conto cavolo ma il
prodotto da solo non sarà mai in grado
di
realizzare la moda sostenibile
il materiale non può risolvere la
promessa di sostenibilità è il sistema
che porta allo sviluppo del prodotto che
deve contemplare dimensioni sociali
dimensioni ambientali è quel sistema lì
che può realizzare un prodotto che
manifesto
della parola sostenibilità
partendo da rispetto sociale e capace di
restare entro dei limiti dei confini
planetari che che sono fisici esistono
oltre quelli non possiamo andare e il
sistema attuale e ve lo dico già è
incapace di far questo perché perché
alla reggina la radice e proprio stato
disegnato da noi in modo completamente
completamente sbagliato non metto in
dubbio e ancora oggi in realtà esistono
dei vestiti che effettivamente
contribuiscono a generare ricchezza
ricchezza sociale ricchezza culturale e
ricchezza estetica ricchezza per la
comunità che li hanno creati esistono
vari un certo punto nella storia se
anche scoperto che l'industria tessile
è un'arma micidiale
estremamente efficace se si vuole anche
arrivare ad accumulare capitale
ricchezza e forse l'errore è sistemico
l'errore proprio progettuale che è stato
fatto è che nel xvii secolo
si è disegnato un sistema basandoci
quasi esclusivamente su quest'ultimo
perlo quello economico finanziario la
crescita ad ogni costo spesso
attribuiamo la la nascita della station
a qualcosa di più o meno recente
vent'anni fa in realtà il seme del fast
fashion c'è del modello di business che
rende l'industria cosi poco sostenibile
oggi è stato piantato nel xvii secolo
dal re luigi xiv re luigi xiv il suo
ministro delle finanze jean baptiste
pull bear
sì me lo immagino io così si siederà si
sedettero a tavolino e realmente
iniziarono a pensa era come sono bastare
la potenza spagnola che ha qui in quel
tempo era veramente la più grande
potenza mondiale e decisero di investire
la produzione di un'industria locale con
la tessile creando il distretto del
lusso francese ma investire la
produzione non basta bisognava
alimentare una domanda la domanda non
c'era e quindi che si fa a tavolino si
crea l'obsolescenza programmata della
moda ovvero si creano due stagionalità
primavera estate e autunno inverno e si
obbligano nobili di corte a cambiarsi
guardaroba almeno durante l'anno anche
se non avevano assolutamente bisogno non
potevano credo immaginare che qualche
secolo dopo saremmo arrivati a 52
collezioni l'anno a centinaia di milioni
di tonellate di vestiti ma il seme è
stato piantato lì il sistema di come
funziona la moda oggi è qualcosa di
radicato ed è da lì allora che bisogna
partire per cambiarla abbiamo capito
qual è la definizione e con la
definizione consapevoli che non
significa sostenibilità
ho iniziato intraprendere un percorso
per metterla in discussione
però lo si può cambiare quello che lo si
vede non è così facile capire quali sono
le implicazioni sistemiche sociali
ambientali di ogni singola maglietta che
viene messa sulla sul pianeta ed ecco
che arriviamo a questo schema qui anche
qua di una semplicità estrema ma che
riassume molto bene come si comporta la
industria della moda allora immaginiamo
che io sono alla moda io soffro un siamo
in un mondo fashion centrico io sto lì
io per produrre tutte queste milioni di
tonnellate di vestiti ogni anno attingo
ad un cerchio esterno natura quello
verde per prendermi acqua terra aria
energia risorse animali magari se si
parlò di lana tutto un processo
estrattivo che deve poi essere
trasformato ancora un'industria
fortemente manifatturiera ed ecco che il
cerchio intermedio quello blu della
società trasforma questi elementi
naturali li manipola mette a
disposizione la loro culto propria
cultura e proprio tempo la propria
esperienza
per consentire a me che solo l'industria
della moda di creare capito addosso a
questo punto io cosa faccio devo qualche
modo dare un output al sistema per
essere sostenibile e attenzione in
fisica natura un sistema in fuori da un
asse di equilibrio cessa di esistere in
pochissimi secondi
la moda è sostenibile equilibrata
sono andato a vedere gli output e se
guardiamo cosa restituisce il sistema
sociale ci rendiamo subito conto che c'è
un disequilibrio sistemico pesante
perché se il primo output ovvio ce
l'abbiamo tutti addosso nessuno è nudo
quale centro sono i vestiti
però a queste questi quantità forse
abbiamo superato il limite forse
l'industria cresciuta di più della sua
funzione stiamo parlando di centinaia di
milioni di tonnellate dei vestiti al 70
per cento composti da fibre fossili
poliestere nylon non riciclabili che
possono impiegare fino a 400 anni per
degradarsi
una delle discariche da s ii più
importanti al mondo più non perché sia
pur troppo importante per la gravità
della situazione sta in ghana a cantà
manto 15 milioni di vestiti ogni
settimana che transitano dal mondo
occidentale vengono portati la i nostri
scarti
qual è secondo output
sulla parola povertà perché uno diceva
ma registra della moda da lavoro a tanta
gente è vero ma se guardiamo i dati
abbiamo un numero ristretto di persone
sempre meno che prendono molta di questa
ricchezza parliamo di un'industria da
qualche trilioni di dollari di fatturato
e se nella lista delle persone più
ricche del mondo ci sono molti
amministratori delegati che rivestono
cariche importanti all'interno dei
grossi gruppi della moda
la contropartita
sono 65 milioni di donne che vivono in
condizioni di povertà estrema non solo
manodopera sottopagata ma anche
una nuova forma di schiavitù moderna e
questo non va bene
terzo output problemi di salute come vi
saluto e dovuto in primis allo stato di
fatiscenza spesso in cui le persone
lavorano negli stabili o nei campi di
deleghe delle fattorie le quali lavorano
per produrre i nostri vestiti seconda
battuta per come vestiti vengono
realizzati a me facciamo un uso
abominevole di sostanze chimiche di
tutta una sorta di schifezze che vengono
messi nei vestiti che interagiscono
negativamente con il nostro epidermica
la pelle che assorbe e poi non ci
pensiamo neanche ma spesso e volentieri
che il problema non finisce lì perché
statisticamente 7 su 10 con il 70 per
cento di questa stanza a dei vestiti con
i volta che vengono lavati rilasciano
sostanze tossiche nell'ecosistema
microplastiche
quindi dal punto di vista sociale stiamo
restituendo a una cosa negativa dal
punto di vista ambientale
è purtroppo la stessa identica cosa
deperimento delle risorse inquinamento e
abbiamo un grosso problema di scarti che
non sono riciclabili e quindi da dove
partire ma la sua diretta ma ha quindi
matteo che lavoro fa sembra un problema
impossibile da risolvere è vero la cosa
bella è che
da questa analisi
comprendendo il problema si possono
tracciare delle direzioni per la
risoluzione possiamo esserne tutte parte
se il 99.9 per cento di tutte le
industrie di moda oggi stanno
concentrando nell'ultima dimensione
creare capi di abbigliamento con
materiali tessuti capace di ridurre il
loro impatto ambientale io vi dico
partiamo dal primo punto di contatto
dell'industria della moda dalla società
se non risolviamo le ingiustizie sociali
sarà impossibile realizzare la
transizione ecologica di cui tanto
parliamo se non mettiamo la filiera
produttiva nelle condizioni di potersi
vede permettere dal punto di vista
psicologico ed economico
di investire tempo e denaro per
abbassare le emissioni di co2 e mettere
un filtro ai propri scarichi è inutile
che ci fissiamo dei gol per rendere i
nostri vestiti più green che un
oggettivo che che aborro
bisogna risolvere la crisi sociale la
crisi ecologica in primis una crisi
sociale e la cosa meravigliosa di questa
cosa che ho detto è che se a meno che
non avremmo industria della moda
difficile che possiamo trovarci a
quattr'occhi con i direttori creativi o
per gli acquisti ai tessuti per
influenzarli ad acquistare prodotti più
responsabili tutti noi possiamo e
abbiamo un'arma e la nostra voce a
nostra disposizione per risolvere invece
la presa e sociale quale entriamo in un
negozio quante volte ci è capitato
richiedere ma chi ha fatto questi
vestiti è stato pagato giusto
questa ragazza è l'arma più efficace per
innescare un'onda sismica di cambiamento
positivo può avere ripercussioni che
vanno ben oltre la nostra immaginazione
nel mio piccolo io oggi sono qui a fare
questo lavoro e parlarvi perché quando
lavoravo per uno dei
persone le aziende da cambiare
un giorno mi trovavo negozio entrato un
ragazzo e dal nulla mi farà ma perché
questa maglietta costa meno di questa e
come fatta questa maglietta da dove
viene non avevo la risposta non avendo
la risposta ha detto devo cambiare e
così si scatta scatta proprio v l'onda
sismica di cambiamento positivo per
mettere in discussione lo status quo
dell'industria della moda e tutti noi
abbiamo potere di farlo grazie
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ogni 4 anni
[Applauso]